(eerie music)
- [Announcer] There's an expression we use
for an unlikely or impossible event.
When something has little or no chance,
we say that it has a
snowball's chance in Hell.
But those are the kinds of odds we like.
In our experiment, we're going
to send a snowball to Hell.
And try to bring it back safely.
(intense drumming)
We'll be attempting
this at an old foundry,
where the molten metal
reaches temperatures
of over 2,000 degrees.
We think this makes it pretty
much to closest thing to Hell
that exists on earth.
To pull this off, we got
GE scientists and engineers
at the Global Research
Center to collaborate
and come up with a solution.
They drew on technology
from the power, aviation,
and healthcare industries,
and developed a vessel
made from a special super alloy.
It was engineered to withstand
incredibly high temperatures,
so we normally use it
to build jet engines,
which have to endure extreme
environmental stresses.
But it was never designed for this.
We're putting the snowball
in this specially-designed
3-D printed holder, and then
placing that in our vessel.
(intense music)
Then we lower it into a vat
and completely cover it
in molten metal slag.
And when we pull it out,
we hope our snowball will be intact.
(intense music)
(chains clinking)
(machine whirring)
(creaking)
(fire crackling)
(chains clinking)
(victorious music)
- Yeah!
(inspirational music)